what's up party people it's your man
it's your home slice it's your boy
jay arie
all right hey oh coffee
okay so it seems like
these reactions are getting pretty big
now so i figured i would join in the fun
and um uh today
i decided almost knocked my coffee over
i did a little bit now
today i've decided that i'm going to
react
to ryan's reaction to sally's reaction
i want to see how deep we can take this
this psychological experience
the raw the nitty-gritty and so uh in
order to do that
i have not watched sally's trailer
reaction to transcendence and i have
also not watched ryan's reaction to
sally's reaction to transcendence
and i haven't watched ryan's trailer
reaction to transcendence
either so getting ready because this is
gonna be meta
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be like
inception
um yeah let's do this
uh
hi i'm ryan and tonight that is ryan
watching the trailer reaction
of sally low monaco's reaction
to transcendence yes second trailer for
transcendence
and uh yeah i still haven't seen the
second trailer awesome i know how it's
always got that joker in the background
you know because it was it was [ __ ]
it was incredible it's incredible
trailer and uh yeah sally what i really
like about sally
i really liked um watching trailers with
her
and i was like yeah you should have your
house ryan's
you better do something to make me happy
if you want to get on my channel
so yeah she has her own little uh
trailer reaction playlist now
uh you know she's very sweet she's
soft-spoken but she's also very sincere
and she can be
really goofy but she's she's just like a
bio of sally
really well this is actually a lot less
awkward than the first time
because i'm a huge fan of johnny depp
lately he's been doing yeah
used to know it just kind of seems like
the cartoony johnny depp that became
after
jack sparrow and i'm really excited i
agree with that i agree with that sally
so do i ryan so i'm going to react to
the trailer so you can react with
me and here we go okay
this is like hanging out with the whole
crew
without any of the stuff that makes
hanging out
the most cool secrets of the universe
there it is that is
part of the universe ah sally you're so
pretty
this is great because like the screen is
like there's one little box then a
bigger box than a bigger box
so i'm just calculating all of my focus
into this one tiny corner of the screen
group known as rift oh oh
ryan notices something in development
i don't think i've ever heard that
reaction to morgan brings
what's wrong with your eyes this is my
first time watching
the trailer reaction
you think this is weird you should be
here doing this
this is even weirder i don't know what
to react to
i look at three people
everybody looks vaguely upset when they
watch
where are you going
everywhere
oh oops sally looks upset i'm so
confused
what transcended okay i'm really
confused i guess they did that on
purpose so that you'd watch the movie
but
he has some good actors in it and can't
go wrong with morgan freeman ryan's
amused i can tell
he also agrees good especially the lego
movie
i agree so thank you guys for watching
go ahead and check out my channel at
salamander sally i know i don't have
much
up on that channel yet but i will i'm
planning to come out with a valentine's
day video which i'm filming tomorrow
also dressing up as sub to this channel
because it's great and the boys are
great
she mentioned me she said my name
specifically
hey she said didn't she say i'm
rewinding this [ __ ] hold on
she said my name specifically being
funny
also dressing up to this channel because
it's great and the boys are great
i hope she doesn't watch this video
oh ryan
i do love you over i am you
horny horny man i do love you
you horny horny man
you